why don't you just give us a little bit
about your background and kind of what
got you into crypto absolutely so Mike
do this a relatively recent entrant into
the crypto ecosystem full time and 2013
started to dabble bought Bitcoin I was
working at the time at Braintree the
payment processor we had customers like
uber Airbnb and obviously all of the big
crypto companies wanting to work with
them so coinbase came to us said hey do
you want to accept Bitcoin in your
gateway and at the time we chose not to
but it developed you know an interest in
my mind you know talking with the
Andreessen folks talking with the
coinbase folks and reading Chou moths
you know everybody should put one two
three percent of their net worth yep in
decrypt though at that time I was like
hmm let's do this so I've been paying
attention to crypto through ownership
since 2013 but I left the ecosystem for
awhile or at the Braintree venmo
started a company called button here in
New York and we had our second child in
the fall and it coincided with a pretty
significant price rise in Bitcoin and
another cryptocurrencies and I went down
the rabbit hole for the first time and
the rabbit hole took about five months
before I really felt comfortable having
conversations with folks who had been in
the ecosystem full-time for a number of
years and my interest was piqued and I
said hey what do I want to do for the
next ten years and after meeting the
people I had met in those five months
you know thinking the ideas I'd thought
and having the conversations I had I
said hey it's time to jump in amazing
and so what specific parts of the
industry do you think are the most
interesting in terms of somebody who's
coming from you know a non-technical
background but has had you know high
degree of success in terms of companies
Eve work that started at etc like what
pulls you in and it's so interesting
yeah so the things that the primary
thing that pulls me in relative to what
I am now calling traditional tech
written a little bit about this is the
multidisciplinary nature of crypto and
blockchain technology you know it's not
just about technology or sales or
marketing or go to mark
you know it's about governance it's
about economics it's about network
security it takes a team of of world
experts to execute on any protocol
project and the other thing that really
attracted me is this the first time yeah
I've been in FinTech for ten years ever
since the Google Wallet days and
Braintree venmo this is the first time
they've actually seen something that
could truly create you know crypto
assets create a parallel financial
system versus what we've historically
called FinTech which are things that can
kind of nibble at the edge of Wall
Street and the traditional financial
system very very interesting and it what
do you think is the biggest mistake
people are making in trying to build
this decentralized financial system so
the biggest thing that I'm seeing right
now the the ecosystem as a whole I think
the biggest mistake that I'm seeing and
it's kind of like a game theory thing
and every rational actor is probably
making the right move in terms of
maximizing their own near-term wealth
but I do think that for crypto to
succeed we're going to need to coalesce
around you know the dominant protocol in
each of the verticals you know they're
being pursued so let's just say Bitcoin
as sound money you know aetherium as you
know the the worldwide universal
computer I'm using extreme shorthand
language here yep z cash or Manero as
the privacy coin now I don't think it's
reasonable to coalesce you know quite
yet but I think it's supremely
problematic when you see you know some
of the leaders of the industry who are
working on five or six projects and I
think it's really problematic when you
see some of the strongest voices in the
industry the fred wilson's of the world
and many others who are you know using
economic incentives to get developers to
work on things that you probably have
very little chance of success like kicks
kin you know relative to the other
platforms out there that can do similar
things better got it and so I think that
part of the beauty of crypto is the fact
that people who have independent
thoughts
and you know kind of do much a research
learn formulate their opinions and
they're able to share them and there's a
little bit less of a you know kind of
group mindset right in traditional tech
if everyone's into scooters everyone's
in scooters right
everyone's doing this and in the the
tribalism and the kind of ferocious
intellectual debates that happen in
crypto I think actually allow a lot of
the best ideas to rise to the top but
that also allows people an environment
to present unpopular or controversial
ideas right what would you say is your
most popular or most controversial idea
that a high degree of people would
disagree with but that you believe so as
somebody who is a Bitcoin maximalist so
basically I'm a Bitcoin maximalist but I
would say that extreme Bitcoin
maximalists would disagree with me as
would people who aren't Bitcoin
maximalist okay there are multiple
definitions of Bitcoin maximalism or
there should be so I fundamentally
believe that Bitcoin has the highest
probability of any coin by a wide margin
of establishing sort of the store of
value use case and perhaps eventually
medium of exchange and Univ account and
becoming you know and it is sound money
yep I think that if Bitcoin went to zero
I think it's you know a very low
probability the cryptocurrency
you know exists in 20 years successfully
at scale at the same time that I'm a
Bitcoin maximalist in terms of value of
the token I believe deeply in the other
projects happening out there many of the
other projects you know including
aetherium including you know Z cash you
know including smaller ones like poet
you know and I think there are a lot of
interesting projects I'm not sure that
value will accrue to the token but I
wouldn't call them [ __ ] coins like I
actually think that you know the token
in some respects Romanies projects is a
way to sort of market and signal
interest and get monetary incentives to
get developers in the ecosystem and I
applaud that even
my more extreme Bitcoin maximalist
friends would probably frown upon that
absolutely well and it's also the
incentive piece right so if you have a
centralized company and you want to
recruit talent right you basically need
to have a team and a mission that is
attractive right you need to have the
ability to pay money right so actual
cash and you've got to usually use some
other incentive mechanism to hire and
retain that talent right and so you see
everything from I'll give people equity
in a company right - I'll provide them
free lunch right and so there's a whole
bunch of different things that you can
do but that's in a centralized you know
single location or multiple single
location type business where everyone's
coming together at the same time no
question when you go to the crypto world
you have this distributed team no
for-profit entity type structure where a
lot of those incentive mechanisms that
you use in kind of traditional you know
company building is not available to the
founders or the people who start these
projects and so the argument it sounds
like you're making is just that those
incentive mechanisms are being replaced
by these tokens you know which have
monetary value associated with them but
they're no different than the free
lunches the equity etc yeah I think
that's close that's close to what I'm
saying and what's interesting is so so
the slight difference is I think a lot
of the investors who are investing in
these tokens do actually believe yet
that many of them will have long term
value for a host of reasons which would
take a multi hour podcast and you'd have
to probably explore right vertical I
think most of them won't have value yep
but I'm more making the point and you
were making this as well that you know
these are the incentives that right now
are encouraging folks to work on these
problems that I think a real are hard
and are worthwhile but it will you know
there will be a day of reckoning when
there's kind of this separation of
Bitcoin aetherium and some of the other
top tokens from some of the tokens that
haven't made progress and I actually
hope that you know some of the scam
coins go away and some of the smaller
market cap
tokens that actually have use cases and
potential utility even just to use a
silly one like spank chain that only has
a market cap of fifteen million and a
believe 15 million in a really
significant industry which could be a
prime use for cryptocurrency I could
look at that and say hey yeah maybe
maybe there's some room for this one to
go up absolutely and so let's talk about
community right in crypto because I
think that there's both the good side
and the bad side let's talk first about
the good side of the community right so
if you look on social and you look at
some of these projects and the tribalism
that goes on there's just a rabid fan
base or rabbit interest right like how
do you see that in comparison to the
traditional technology startup world
where you know people always trying to I
want customers that love me right - now
this rabbit you know interest in the
crypto world yep so in the traditional
tech world outside of gaming and and
real like consumer tech eSports and
things of that nature and there's more
examples but I'm just those are a few of
the examples where you see these rabid
fan bases and I actually think crypto is
most analogous to those rabid ones to
sports teams in the real world in tech
you see you know developer fan bases and
and they'll go to Google i/o and you
know f8 but those are very different you
know very controlled experiences in the
crypto ecosystem people come with and
you've heard this before I'm not saying
anything particularly novel in this area
but you know with with almost a
religious belief and an anchoring and a
strong bias and and as strong a tribal
nature to associating with specific
projects as I've ever seen yep
and frankly it's because they've had
access I mean it's because these folks
look at themselves as angel investors
you know true investors are the earliest
stages of these projects because it's
clearly you know nearly almost none of
them are even close to fully developed
yet and so I think that's a positive the
same time it can be a curse so an
example of where it's genuine is is
clearly aetherium right and clearly
bitcoin but that's been talked about a
lot but clear the theorem from a devil
per perspective and tons of developers
you know flocking to it solidity is a
language that's not just you know if
you're in specific but folks if folks
really want to work on the etherium
blockchain and with and so you're seeing
absent services built on top and so I
consider that a a really healthy organic
natural community at the same time I see
really unhealthy communities so you know
the obvious canonical example of that is
ripple so ripple has a centralized
structure where the ripple core
basically says hey we put our tokens in
escrow but but still you know they're
obviously under their control and
they're released over a period of time
and then you know they have a host of
real people who are ripple extremists
and and who knows what their motives are
and you know what their compensation is
and and you know why they're doing what
they do but they really become kind of a
hive mind in public and really come
after anybody who questions the validity
of XRP and of ripple and then you can go
one level ba past that which is just
false and fake communities right and and
you know it has echoes of what happened
and you know our election and and you
know BOTS and it ripples the case where
there's certainly real people who are
supporters but there's no question that
there are tens of thousands of BOTS
associated with ripple and and do you
think that's something where the company
and the people in and around the company
are actively trying to create this stuff
or do you think it's a thing where
community members who like the project
who hold the coins right have a
financial incentive and seeing it
succeed or trying to push that narrative
through through you know social channels
etc yeah so the the ripple Corp team is
an exceptionally professional talented
team they they truly are like I've
spoken with them I
no you know some of them personally and
they're very talented they're talented
yeah both at creating you know
functioning financial products yep and
they're also very talented at you know
increasing the value of things related
you know to the corporation they're
working for and the token is clearly
part of that right so so Brad Garlin
houses comments about you know pilots
that might have eight transactions total
globally ever that yeah they issue a
press release about you know those are
clearly strategic decisions they make
where they know it's not material but
will impact the price of the token so so
the management that ripple clearly does
things to move the token price separate
from actually creating value at the core
product at the same time they have a
credible team the product team is doing
a good job on you know a number of you
know financial institution and Bank
products that they're working with and
increasingly you know getting more and
more partners that being said you know
if they were just a traditional equity
backed company it would be valued
nowhere near what they're valued at
today and then to the question of the
community in the bots I think they could
do more to police it and it's not in
their interest to do so today so they
don't and you know I've experienced it
and I know many other folks who have
like my friend Jeff Goldberg who's
explored the ripple bot problem and they
invite you know the ripple team
definitely invites many of the most
prominent you know tweeters affiliated
with them to all of their events and
getting sort of encourages them to
continue with the sort of minute mini
celebrity game but I don't think salafi
one and that they know helps to
artificially support the token price so
I think that that argument is popular
and you know relatively well except
about a lot of people I would take the
opposite side and I don't even know if I
have a different opinion about Ripple
specifically right I don't know one I
haven't spent enough time with them to
have an opinion on them but the
mechanisms of
you know let's walk through so if they
announce pilots right up there early you
could say hey they're doing it to
manipulate price right or you could say
they are being overly transparent right
the the idea of them working with people
who are big fans of a brand right every
company in the world does that who has
any sort of size you know public
influencers right the industry you know
consensus absolutely does it and so I
think I think one of the things that I
try to wrap my head around I don't have
an answer here right but but I think is
is really interesting is you know part
of the ethos of crypto right in general
as an industry is decentralized you DEP
distributed teams kind of all of that
that goes in that bucket at the same
time it's experimentation it's you know
trying different ideas not getting tied
to the sacred cows all this stuff and so
you know in the case of a ripple or
other projects those are almost in
direct conflict with each other right
because actually what they're doing is
they're doing experimentation they're
doing you know they're really pushing
the edge and trying to figure out you
know do these new models work and how do
they drive value but they aren't
decentralized they aren't distributed
right and so how do you think like where
that log is so it's it's a great
question so I think one way that they
could basically eliminate all doubt is
to say hey instead of compensating
ourselves in this token XRP which you
know the founding team has the
leadership has David Schwartz as they
could choose to you know basically
renounce those tokens and you take value
in more value in the equity of ripple
Corporation which clearly has a
connection to X or P the token but I
think it would reduce questions as to
whether they're you know are ulterior
motives god when they are announcing
things that's just one simple thing yep
again that being said yes structurally
it's really difficult for that
management team to execute without
people asking questions externally just
given the structure of of course
relation how it's died
tokens and that's just just one example
that's even a healthier community than
some of the other ones out there you
know the the the Tron community right I
mean it's it's it's a total scam it's
not even worth getting into that but you
know you mentioned Tron and say scam and
you know you're gonna have a hundred
bots in your inbox quickly all right so
skiers let's talk about the media in
crypto it's a sign of something you care
about a lot it seems like there are
three separate buckets of media outlets
or types right so you've got the crypto
media these are people who super
well-connected an industry they really
understand what's going on they do a
fairly good job in terms of reporting
that you know in detail accurately maybe
a little bit smaller audiences right but
but very much hey these are people who
understand this industry then you've got
the traditional media right which you
know depending on who you're talking
about may or may not understand what's
going on accuracy is questionable
sometimes right and the way that they
are delivering the message can lead to a
lot of retail investors changing their
opinion about certain tokens of acting
differently exception in the market and
then the third bucket is what I call it
the citizen journalists right which is
you know these Twitter accounts that
explode that all of a sudden you know
about a whale panda right or you know
bully esq right these guys I'm gonna
Nick Carter you know they have a voice
right I've got a publishing platform and
and what they're doing people want to
hear and so they grow these audience and
now they Vinnie compleanno I am I'm just
having fun but they're actually
providing a legitimate value and and so
through that like how do you see that
ecosystem and you know relationship
between the three playing out over the
next you know five ten years yeah so I
think all of them are important
so today but I think you know those
three are all somewhat insular okay so I
think the way that all three of those
types of media today are writing is in a
very trade oriented manner and meaning
price like talking about price and what
is happing in a market where people are
looking to trade so that would be one
exam
yep but another is like basically
writing about aetherium governance or
you're writing about yeah like why has
price gone up or down in the last six
months yeah if I gave that article to a
friend who's an engineer working in
traditional tech but with not a lot of
knowledge about the crypto ecosystem
they probably need to read like four
precursor pieces to God at the point
where they understood it so the way I
think of those three categories right
now and I'll just start there yep is you
know I look at like coin desk being the
former so there's a sort of trade
magazine type type of ecosystem and and
really coin desk is the only one that
has a brand that even in this ecosystem
stands out yep this ego system is like a
pretty de minimis small number of folks
okay you know compared to the global
interest in cryptocurrency of course
same technology and then you've got
Bitcoin magazine coin Telegraph CCN
which copies everybody else's stuff I
mean it's just a small small you know
I'm sorry it's a big group of brands the
write very similar things yep okay then
to your point you've got the Bloomberg's
the fortunes who you know and then
there's a host of others who are running
about this new york times but I think
Bloomberg a four which are doing the
best job and they have folks on the beat
who are deeply informed and they write
and they break news right and they write
some really good pieces and they write
some pieces that I wouldn't write that
aren't good right I think there's a
group that's a little bit different than
that they have better editorial judgment
you know CNBC is a disaster it's just
terrible for the industry why shitshow
it's basically no-holds-barred
completely unethical so basically you've
got these folks on air Brian Kelly you
know crypto man ran who blocked me on
Twitter for calling him out for being an
absolute shill of coins that he owns
mm-hmm buys them and then tweets about
them you know through his private
vehicle CNBC literally allows people who
are telling people how to buy
cryptocurrencies and informing and
educating them supposedly to literally
run hedge funds on the side [ __ ] joke
it's embarrassing makes me a rate and it
hurts people it hurts people's pockets
they're a sham
okay so CNBC is different than everybody
else yep it's embarrassing and Comcast
should be embarrassed to allow this on
television and it's probably the thing
I'm most passionate right now
I hear less about Ripple and about CNBC
being held accountable for hurting the
common investor mm-hmm they're terrible
for the industry and they mislead people
so sorry for going off on that tangent
but I think it's important that's what
you believed in that I believe it deeply
and you know so that's sort of the mass
market if you asked people walking down
the street a thousand people
you know what's the biggest brand and
media of Bitcoin crypto blockchain name
all the terms I think they'd probably
say Newburgh you know a thousand people
even in New York maybe a couple would
say coined us but they say Bloomberg
fortune New York Times a couple of
theirs have that name brand recognition
and then lastly yeah the last category
said I think you sort of aggregated on
Twitter and medium rights and personal
blogs and the medium and it is the
richest source of high signal
information in the industry I agree it's
abundance I mean just absolute abundance
it's a shame that I think medium you
know needs to hire somebody a
cryptocurrency expert you know to really
curate this and highlight the best stuff
they're not doing a good job there it
frankly is the industry we just need to
find some rich person to give them a
bunch of tokens to hire somebody to do
this because it's so wonderful and I'm
you know every week now integrating the
best on medium yeah do you think that
because they're practitioners it's you I
was going to say D people in the
industry do you think it's because
they're the other types of media are
basically reporting what other people
are doing and what you get on medium for
you know specifically they are talking
to them and you're talking to experts
and look everybody has an agenda
versus I think that it sorry to
interrupt but I think the direction you
were had it is you know these this
authentic deep I've thought about this
thing that I personally care about you
can Nick Carter some of these folks
don't even have the real names how sue
fly who's very bright a number of folks
you know who have gotten me really
interested in
and economics yeah miles emani's of the
world and its original ideas yeah right
its original ideas yep your daily
newsletter yet Ryan sulcus yeah those
are the folks the folks day in and day
out who are living and breathing this
for the folks who are sharing right now
the best information and I'm actually
writing a blog post that will be
published tomorrow in the block which is
my new business which I haven't talked
about yet but will be publishing and
somebody asked me this morning on
Twitter hey why do you guys talk so much
about what you're building instead of
actually building and I listed a few
reasons but you know I think it's
important that we talk about it because
we have so few believers we have such so
much information so much change so fast
so much of what's being shared isn't
accurate
and therefore it's really important for
the folks who are in the know who have
that judgment and good curation to talk
absolutely well and I think what we're
seeing is this is probably one of the
first industries where part of it is the
nature of crypto part of it is the
nature of just communication and tools
outside of crypto is the practitioners
the operators the engineers are able to
talk directly to audiences without the
that the the middleman right the the VP
etc I mean you know and we're seeing it
by the way we're seeing it in our
president does it Elon Musk is doing it
right Kanye West I mean you go through
there's a bunch of people who are
figuring out I can talk directly to my
audience like Jeremy Rubin wrote a piece
on hey you know giving you know sort of
airdrop tokens giving wealth to people
that I read this morning and by the way
I'm being completely honest I read the
whole thing and I didn't understand any
but like it made some sense to me and I
loved sharing it and putting it out
there and you know having it be debated
and discussed and another guy respect
greatly Jeremy Gardner said hey I don't
necessarily agree with that and it's a
wonderful you know it's just wonderful
to see all these different viewpoints
coming from different backgrounds so I
mathematical you know some practical you
know having these discussions it's
really exciting
absolutely and then so what do you think
is the you know with what you're doing
with the block right so well first tell
us little bit about what you're doing
there and then we can talk about how
this relates to the
fourth type of media that I don't
believe has existed and it's starting to
exist so it's basically media about
median information and community around
the crypto and blockchain ecosystem that
reaches let's just say I'm making up
numbers here are 1 million people in the
world know a lot right those first three
categories we talked about are super
serving those 1 million people who
already know a bunch of stuff yep
well hey there's a hundred million
people and I'm just again making up
numbers but you know relatively I think
the hundred Exmoor the ratios are
probably somewhat accurate who are
getting terrible information they're
just following random twitter feeds you
know pump groups on telegram they don't
have access to the best information the
insider information that we're fortunate
enough to have access to so I looked at
this ecosystem and said hey I really
feel like this is where I want to be for
the next 10 years I've been successful
in the past so I can take a ten to
fifteen year horizon and I'd love to do
this the rest of my life absolutely but
I want this industry or this ecosystem
to succeed so badly and I'd love to do
this for my the rest of my life so the
block is crypto simplified and the whole
idea here is that we take these concepts
that you and I understand probably many
of our listeners understand and we
basically start at the base layer of
those and then build up from there and
build this education base create what I
call a reddit meet slack and I've
created a slack group it's a thousand
people strong where people are learning
from one another I think people learn
invest in groups as we see from telegram
but effectively liberating this and
giving it to people so they they can
discuss the news the analysis the topics
of eBay together so anyway the block has
launched a newsletter that we publish
you know every other day our websites
launching at the end of September and
it's going to be that thing that you
check in your phone for a quick take on
what's happening and you know we'll
aggregate all of the analysis and other
information but it's approachable and we
want to reduce people are fearful I was
fearful when I came into this industry
five six seven eight months ago we want
to reduce the fear so people can jump in
and learn when a lot of it too is you
know if I said hey go learn everything
you can about quantum you know mechanics
right you you would say I don't know
anything right
maybe your expert but yeah and so you
would start googling right you'd find
some okay hey these look like these are
the people who understand a bunch I can
search on YouTube okay I'm gonna go
watch these videos I'm gonna read you
know some stuff off of Wikipedia and I'm
gonna find a book and an expert and you
just go down this rabbit hole and you
eventually come up with oh all right I
understand that some at some degree of
of knowledge the problem when crypto is
those people those videos etc don't look
anything like we've ever seen before
right it's pseudo anonymous accounts on
Twitter it's these secret telegram
groups it's these videos where I've
literally seen people who are incredibly
intelligent are doing videos and their
faces are covered yeah right it's like
medium sort of gives text credibility
yeah you know we're looking to have the
block you give a number of these
concepts these voices credibility and
then got it to basically take a lot of
what they're doing with their
endorsement and present it in a way that
people feel comfortable and then we're
actually going to ground that in a
physical community as well so we're
starting here in New York with something
called the block out we work it's a
co-working space it's going to be
launching this fall and we're gonna
invite crypto projects you know 100 plus
people to join us and folks who you know
are part of the block community will be
able to drop in and so it's really
grounding I'm sorry it's it's really you
know we think right now New York is one
of the top three if not the top I mean
it's a crypto ecosystems in the world so
we'll start here and we'll see how it
manifests itself that physical plus
digital community that's welcoming and
and one other thing I want to say there
are some other fantastic teams that are
doing this right now I mean again huge
kudos to you with with your newsletter
which i think is much more approachable
than a lot of what i've seen out there
the team at Masari crypto is doing some
phenomenal work I mean they have a team
ryan sulcus just wrote about it this
morning a guy I respect tremendously and
you know 125 folks who are who are
offering up you know analysis of tokens
and things so they're working for
transparency and wealth of information
and token daily is another one these are
different thing
token daily who is having just amazing
people country
like they have on medium historically
and then allowing conversation around it
so the block isn't the only one and I
think we're all gonna be able to work
together and I'm just like it's just I
think this is the time and the place and
what's great is because price has gone
to [ __ ]
over the last six eight months we can
all just focus on building yep and you
know this is not a permanent thing I
think we all believe in this technology
I mean sort of in this ecosystem and its
ability to change so many industries and
to change money when we come out of this
it's going to be wonderful that we've
all been working heads down it's like
the 2008/2009 quote-unquote crisis I
think you may have said it you said it
in your newsletter you birthed uber
birthed Airbnb and some of the greatest
companies of the last decade so it's
really exciting for sure what what do
you think is if you could wave a magic
wand right and change one thing about
the crypto industry what would you
change so I would change the I would
change this mindset that I sometimes see
where people judge others and this is
not universal
but I do see a significant portion of
people who judge others either
explicitly or just you can kind of see
it in the back of their head by how long
they've been 100% immersed in the
industry as somebody who has immersed
myself fully recently but been you know
caring about it and an owner for a long
time I think it's [ __ ] you know when
somebody says hey you know you weren't
around when we did XYZ and therefore you
don't understand I would and my retort
would be hey you know explain it to me
because the way my whole mission is that
the person who joins in three years has
a platform in the block where nobody's
going to treat them like that
absolutely scare them off that's really
the biggest thing I think and I think
you're bringing I would change the sort
of lack of focus on design and the last
thing I change is frankly this and I
wrote about it this morning and a tweet
is this sort of like pre pre sale pre
pre pre pre pre sale like triple pre pre
pre pre pre sale and I know meltem you
know probably talked about it this
morning the [ __ ] coin waterfall it's
disgusting it's a terrible terrible
funding mechanism I know we're moving
away from it
but you know a number of very prominent
investors have benefited from it and I
just think it sends a bad signal and I
think some of those folks should stay
quiet for a while and stop with their
moralizing got it in - out of all of
this it you know let's fast-forward 10
years you know you've built an
incredible company a bunch of other
people have continued to build what
they're doing what do you think is the
outcome of all of this talent and
capital that's flowing into this space
right is it Bitcoin becomes a global
reserve currency and nothing else
is it Bitcoin plus everything else
that's being built like where do we end
up yes with ten years I mean it's hard
to pick the date right of course because
it's gonna base it you know it's it's
like the fall of blockbuster the beauty
is when people listen to the podcast if
they listen to it from a year from now
ten years is still ten years away
exactly at some point yeah so you know
I'm hopeful it's a very low probability
that Bitcoin becomes like just from a
purely probability like do I believe it
like I ascribe a higher probability to
it yep that Bitcoin does become you know
the global reserve currency and you know
eats the US dollars dominate what what
do you think the probability is right
now not what you believe but just like
did the kind of sober probability I'm in
opens you know below like below 5% okay
but that's fair you know that's currency
is like that's hey we're talking
hundreds of trillions of dollars worth
of value getter for Bitcoin I may have
actually is there even hundreds of
trillions I may be off by an order of
numbers but but there's a lot of value
to that um you know but but you know
becoming a better gold like in my mind
it's so obvious that it's a near
certainty yep that you know like if Paul
Krugman and I saw each other we wouldn't
even be able to talk because like we we
literally would be from such a different
grounding of ideas but do you think
something like that actually believes
what he's saying I believe Nouriel does
not believe what he's saying and as a
troll I believe Paul Krugman does
believe what he's saying and he's just
old got it and by old I don't mean it in
an ageist way I mean it old
of economic philosophy got it made that
makes it what makes money and what he
has seen throughout his life okay so we
put less than 5% chance that Bitcoin
becomes global now Jack said you know
it's gonna happen in ten years you know
P Rashard will probably not allow me it
anymore if his Bitcoin maximalist
interest for saying less than five so
the hopeful you know part of me says one
in five chance yep and I think over not
a ten-year horizon but you know 20 30
years okay and then what outside of
Bitcoin what happens to all of this you
know tens of billions of dollars that
now I've come into the space
you know thousand people news is it's
not that much money right like if you
look at it you know outside of Bitcoin I
expect Bitcoin dominance to actually
increase through the remainder of the
year literally as I was taking the
subway up here I said you know Chris
Bernanke said what do you think is gonna
be one big thing that happens and a
milestone to watch in the credit
industry this year I think Bitcoin
dominance going over 70% is something
I'm gonna keep an eye out for and I
think very well might happen because I
think you're going to see people realize
that most of these protocols that have
significant value are nowhere close to
delivering anything
yep and so that doesn't mean Bitcoin
will skyrocket I just think you're going
to see I'm actually hopeful whether
happens this year or next year to see
you know every coin not rise and fall
you know the same percentage every day I
lost my train of thought on your
original question actually so what do
you think happens to everything outside
of Bitcoin in terms of Bitcoin so I
think you're gonna see a flight to
quality so things like a theory I'm
right now is a 35 billion today market
cap like maybe a little less you know
that's not unreasonable for you know
Airbnb 30 billion it's not unreasonable
for the ambition and the potential of
that platform and the developer activity
it's certainly way over its skis I mean
it you know but look when stripe was
valued at nine billion dollars having
been somebody who was competing with
them I was like holy [ __ ] yeah that's an
overpayment and handled like key through
blah at all but that guy was dead right
about that company being a generation
company and I love the Collison so the
brothers who run the company are
incredible entrepreneurs great people
and geniuses and so you know sometimes
things surprise you to the upside that
you never could see because you were
thinking of the business model in a
different way and I just couldn't
imagine stripe turning a simple few
lines of code into something they had
the margins that it has just based on my
knowledge of Braintree so when you look
at a theory and you see you know hey you
know crashes when one specific gap you
know gets a ton of users or in a given
day it's easy to say hey they're not
gonna you know there's nothing there
right yep and by the way like my
probability bet I would say there's more
likelihood that there's not than there
is but it was very reasonable the thing
that the value of etherium you know
increases significantly
so my point isn't about etherium my
point is i expect a flight to quality
yeah and I really I don't know if I
expected or I hope for it you know I
hope neo I hope I hope Tron
you know just absolutely evaporate
absolutely and then what um what do you
think is the most important company in
crypto today yeah so I've long thought
this and again this will rile you know
most of my closest crypto folks of the
philosophy I think the most important
company company not encrypt though in
the history of crypto is coinbase why I
would doubt they are the first folks who
made crypto who attracted investors and
got the backing of folks who the
financial industry took seriously so
Union Square Ventures and injuries and
Horowitz they are the first company that
made it something where people like me
who were intellectually interested in it
felt comfortable and safe putting money
you know into this this token that was
vapor effectively at the time 2013 you
know I don't believe it's vapor I've
done a lot more studying today you know
my brother invested you know I had
convinced other folks to do so and they
stuck with it and they grew and they've
evolved right I don't agree necessarily
with everything that their CEO says
and you know one of their founders has
moved on but the company the entity
itself folks like Dan Romero who have
been there since the beginning and
amazing people dance fantastic stay
strong you know take criticism and have
really brought this to the masses and I
am so sympathetic to people who bring
important technology the masses
I think engineers and and sort of like
really extreme religious minded people
don't believe and understand how
important that is
so coinbase is super easy to hate and is
against much of the sort of libertarian
philosophy of why some people support
Bitcoin for example but we wouldn't be
here without them it's coming they
almost went out of business
Apple years ago and is now a behemoth
and you know I'm very optimistic about
their future I'm hopeful for their
future I'm rooting for them because I
think they've done so much for the
industry I think they're the single most
important company in the industry that's
awesome
alright last question for you is what is
what do you do on a daily or weekly
basis that you think has formed much of
your opinion in this space so the number
one thing that forms my opinions that
that helps me to learn and that directs
and guides me to where I should be
paying attention and I'm very fortunate
for this is telegram and and I mean you
know three telegram groups that I value
you're very very highly I can't name
them it's like yeah once you name them
you're out but it's like a a real
journalist I'll get you to name them but
because you're in I think all of them so
you know it you can't pay attention to
everything about them right I mean it's
just it's overload but if you pick and
choose
you're gonna happen upon and certainly
when I was learning and I had more time
paternity leave I was fortunate enough
but but starting my day with telegram
moving some of those thoughts to Twitter
and then engaging has been the most
important thing by learning and then
broadcasting my ideas on Twitter and
sharing has been what's helped me build
my
company and our company the block so the
two folks who are already you know have
accepted dot online mark rodowskys my
co-founder and editor in chief and I
can't name the person who's joining
there's a head of research in a week and
a half
both quote-unquote met me on Twitter
right Maisie and I'm speaking to two
more people over the next couple days
and have had multiple conversations with
them and I'm gonna close them I hope
they're listening up this gets published
really soon are also folks that you know
I met through Twitter and Twitter is the
new LinkedIn it is LinkedIn it's just a
total [ __ ] show it's a wonderful
wonderful broadcast medium it's a
terrible terrible business connection
amazing amazing alright man thank you so
much for doing this this is awesome I
think I think you've got a very unique
perspective on the world and and all the
best of luck to you and we'll talk soon
yeah I mean literally right back at you
I appreciate the opportunity and a lot
of fun buddy all right sounds good
all right so all right so we started
allowing people ask me one question when
they come on which which scares the hell
out of me
but yeah one question do you have for me
okay what is one important thing that
you have strongly asserted over the past
six months about the tokenization of
securities that you believed at the time
and that you strongly disagree with or
disagree with today so I think that
there are a number of things that I
strongly believed and I can't say that I
strongly disagree with them but I am
much less excited about and I think how
I arrived at being less excited about
or thinking that they are less important
probably make sure the to and that makes
sense like I am you know me I'm so you
can I say things and get excited yeah
well I think part of it is education
expression the technical side of like
you know let's go deeper into the tech
and understand exactly how this is going
to work and then to is having more data
points from a timeline perspective right
so just watching some of this planning
and market trying you know exactly so I
think the there's two things one is the
idea that tokenization is going to occur
because of the technology I'm probably
less excited about so the idea that you
know instantaneous settlement 24-hour
trading fractional ownership like I
think these are all features that are
important and interesting but I don't
think that's actually why people are
going to use the tokenized security so
we interact with them I think now I'm a
much bigger believer that it's a user
behavior where people's interface into
digital world it's gonna be a digital
wallet in order for them to have that
digital lock act like a bank in a
brokerage account they can hold stocks
bonds currencies commodities yep and in
order for anybody with an asset to allow
that person to hold those assets they
have to digitize it right so it's more
of the digital aspect and in the support
of a digital wallet than it is all the
transactions etc so I think that's one
thing I've kind of walked back into a
different you know kind of thesis around
ya know I love that like actually I
remember some of the rebuttals to some
of the things you were saying four or
five months ago
yep and like that seems eminently
reasonable as a rebuttal because
absolutely no user experience if it's in
the place where you do the other things
then you know absolutely do it if you
can make it as easy as the other things
are for sure yeah and then I think the
second thing that I would argue on it's
totally secure specifically is the idea
that people are going to want to buy
this for liquidity etc I think that I'm
very much in the camp of at the end of
the day if you're gonna buy tokenized
equity you're going to evaluate it as
equity if you're gonna buy took a nice
real estate you're gonna evaluate it as
real estate right it's still I think you
know if the asset is good
people will want it and therefore it
will get a premium in price if the asset
is bad and it you know is not gonna
appreciate value etc then people are not
gonna want it's gonna deeper it's going
to decrease in price and so this idea
that if I have capital that I want to
invest I already understand the asset
classes right stocks bonds could there's
these commodities the technology in
between me and that asset is probably
less important to me right now
tokenization for a whole host of reasons
I think is actually going to be the
winner right in terms of what of what
people are going to use but I don't
think the mass consumer or mass investor
is as interested in oh I bought the
tokenized version of the equity versus
just not as easy transparency yeah they
just want this one by the equity right
and so the the the egregious example is
no wave runs around and says I bought
electronic shares of Apple settle in
DTCC
instead they just say I shares an apple
same thing whether it's tokenizer so the
key thing and what's your biggest will
do I get two questions I'm going for it
all right go ahead what's your biggest
worry or do you worry that we you know
maybe end up in an analogous situation
to you know the Blythe masters induced
you know CDO situation of two thousand
eight two thousand so I think that
tokenization is not going to be the
cause I think that people will do it
right but I also think that's gonna
happen with Bitcoin and it ends with a
lot of right with you know every kind of
future and of course derivatives
ultimately I haven't fully formulated
this yet but if you think about
engineers really good engineers that
understand this kind of decentralized
distributed world they have a superpower
that Wall Street has never had to the
you know available to them when you take
those people who have a superpower and
allow them to play in a financial system
that they probably don't have a deep
understanding or experience in there's a
lot of good that comes out of it because
they don't know which rules are not
supposed to break right the unwritten
rules kind of disappear but that also
means they haven't learned the lesson
from past bubbles and
and so I think what we're gonna see is
all of the elements of Wall Street are
gonna get exasperated right and so the
good and the bad yeah and so when that
happens you bring these people with a
super power into that financial system
just buckle up because you're gonna get
both up and down and I guess my hope
would be that because we have these sort
of religious people you know who are
feeling like hey this is our ecosystem
that there will be you know a level of
checks and balances and transparency but
it's gonna be fun to watch we'll see how
it evolved absolutely that is the that
is the hope so look man I appreciate you
coming on obviously best of luck with
what you're doing I think that the that
you're definitely off to the races here
and we'll talk soon likewise thank you
so much buddy your hat